hey guys it's henry golding here and i
am going to be doing the wired
autocomplete
interview
do i have to answer these questions
[Music]
all right first up what henry golding so
um let's have a look
what languages does henry golding speak
i can only speak like one language and
that's pretty much
english very broken bahasa malayu which
is from malaysia
but growing up in southeast asia you
kind of pick up
a little bit of chinese a little bit of
indian a little bit of
bahasa fluently just one language next
question
boop what films has henry golden been in
my career started not too long ago
uh crazy rich asians was the first the
last being
snake eyes which comes out july 23rd
what is henry golding
doing right now isn't that weird that
people sort of like
question like what am i doing perhaps
what if i was like sat on the toilet
like taking a deuce like
that's crazy some people have a weird
imagination
whoa all right does henry golding
have an english accent i did
i grew up in the uk it's kind of
kind of gone here there and everywhere
just because my wife kind of has this
international accent i've lived in the
states for so long so it's
kind of wavering slightly
does henry golding have tattoos i have
lots of tattoos
i come from a tribe in uh malaysia
called the iban and so i have a huge
tattoo here
i got tattoos on my shoulder my ribs on
the sort of the inside of my arms
not knowing that i was going to be an
actor uh so they are the bane of
of my existence when you need to cover
them up so you have to come in like
three four hours
earlier so probably no more tattoos
does henry golding have a child i do
have a child
a new one three months old beautiful
baby
daughter she is the the ruler of my
kingdom right now
does henry golding have siblings i have
two siblings i was the youngest
of three and so i always had kind of
uh the youngest child syndrome of being
spoiled and getting away with
everything um and of course being
a mommy's boy uh that helped as well
does henry golding do martial arts i
had not done a tremendous amount of
martial arts i did a lot of sort of
boxing and muay thai kind of growing up
and stuff like that so a foundational
basis of martial arts but they really
put us through the ringer
for snake eyes give me
can henry golding
sing no
there was actually secretly
uh a scene in crazy rich asians where we
first meet
nick young um and he enters into this
sort of
karaoke bar where rachel
is seeing her heart out failing
miserably and so he joins her on sat
um and sings this terrible song but a
duet that
sort of cements you their love and their
kind of
jokiness together it's been cut out the
film possibly because of my terrible
saying it's out there somewhere ask john
m true to uh
to dig it out can henry golding
be related to ellie goulding i always
get that that's the weirdest thing
she has a u in her golding um and i
don't
not related at all if she could impart
some of her singing skills to me
i'd be forever grateful but sadly i
don't think that's possible
how henry golding how
old is henry golding i think i'm
34 now megan manager
34 it's true she controls my entire life
so she knows better than i do
i'm 34 years old guys i knew that um how
did henry golding
get into acting funny story i suppose
it was forcibly john chu
was looking for a an actor to fill this
very sort of pivotal role uh in this
little movie called crazy rich asians
they were like on the last kind of
three weeks of the deadline that warner
brothers gave them to find
somebody anywhere in the world they
could one of the
accounting ladies knew about the search
and was like this is the guy that you
need to find i don't know what he
does now i met him five years ago at
this event his name's henry golding
here's his name passed it to the line
produced the line producer was like oh
maybe this is the guy passes the name to
john long story short
i didn't want to audition because i
wasn't an actor at that stage
so i turned down the role i end up
being stalked by john him finding my
number somehow
and then forcibly telling me are you
absolutely
effing ridiculous like this is a chance
of a lifetime
you need to read you need to put
yourself on tape for me and i was like
well ah
sure and that was it that was the uh
that was the rest is history as they say
last one how did henry golding meet his
wife
i'll make this one quick she stopped me
in the middle
of the dance floor of a club in
singapore
new year's day so 101
11 she stopped me and said to me
why haven't you said hello to me yet i'm
leaving in the next couple days you'll
never ever see me again what are you
going to do about it
does snake guys ever talk
we do in this movie uh this is an origin
film
so uh of course we're going to have him
speak his part
tell of his challenges and of course he
is very calculative
in in what he says because in this movie
he's trying to achieve
something and that might not be good
that might not be bad um
but he has his own sort of motivations
does snake eyes
get her oh yes he absolutely gets beaten
up
a tremendous amount because he is early
on in his training he isn't the
the weapon that we all know him to be he
learns from his
his sort of hardships dustin guys
die no doesn't it guys
ever show his face yes does janae guys
use guns oh hells yes he's got the
the famous sort of uzi and katana duo
going on but in this iteration uh i do
get to sort of fire off a few
few guns but majority of the work is is
definitely
with the the old slice and dice i'm
going to rip these out
sorry there we go is snake eyes a ninja
that is a good
question because we all presume
that he's sort of a a ninja and a badass
the russian kage clan
create ninjas and that is their heritage
and culture and world and that's where
he trained
but technically he's not a ninja as
such but he is trained in the weight of
the ninja
it's snow eyes ngi joe
good or bad
in this origin film we get to see the
makings of
the snake eyes that we all love he
perhaps has a much more of a challenging
route
to becoming a gi joe than thought of
before
that is yet to be seen in the movie you
have to catch that
it's snake ass and storm shadow brothers
they are absolute blood brothers they've
been sort of joined in ways
uh that honor and duty
can only bind uh men and women
and that is a bond that is unbreakable
and is one of the
most iconic relationships that flip-flop
from hating
to being an arch-nemesis to fighting for
the right cause the same thing
um back to hating each other and then
hugging it out on on sort of christmas
days and
forgiving and forgetting um is snake ass
blind no definitely not um isn't it guys
better than batman why you got to do
that
guys why why why why bring batman into
this
he is one of the most
amazing humans
in comic book lore but so is snake eyes
so that is a battle i would pay to watch
crossover you guys been searching a lot
on google huh
what is snake eyes oh no
oh you're gonna have to help me what is
snake eyes
real name ah so that is one of the
mysteries
that uh has been carried throughout this
movie as well as
all the iterations of the comic books
and films his real name is classified so
you ain't getting enough of me what does
snake eyes
look like this guy right here
what are snake eyes characteristics
the guy is a man of very few words
um he is a man of his word
he honors that of his promise
to a fault so he's a man you would want
by your side finished
well that's it thanks for watching guys
thanks for googling
not as many sordid questions as i
thought they could have been
so thanks for staying pg